Monday morning
[Music]
you're running for press you socialists
cheat avoiding the shows where you'd
have to speak of this communist game you
want here at home
climb down a rope of blankets and sheets
evaded the guards you land on this Creek
it's time to get back to the old folks
home
I'm reading your plan over again and
that's not a word that I comprehend
except when you shine in love Bernie
always with feeding backwards
please
foreign
[Music]
your bedroom window how did it break you
left the pills
[Music]
you climb down a road
[Music]
because you're so cheap if I don't need
a gun you don't need three homes
foreign
[Music]
your hair is
everywhere
screaming in stability
along with yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
screaming instability
[Music]
your house
everywhere
screaming in stability
[Music]
your hair is everywhere
[Music]
screaming instability
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
first change
[Music]
foreign
I've been in a bad habit of breaking my
pins yeah and so tool man here gave me
this this is like three it's a tactical
pen it's gonna be used as a weapon I
think it is a DNA scraper too so uh
Gerald I hope you enjoy the feds uh glad
to be with you uh we have uh boys at a
busy day but busy I mean it's it's not
that busy so we're going to be talking
about Russia today we have a we'll be
talking about the Karen documentary in
the CBC I don't know if you know what
this is we've teased it before but now
we have exclusive footage but Jill and I
disagree a bit on Russia yeah I don't
think that they'll use nukes he thinks
they might we're not that far apart but
for the sake of arguing on air we'll
we'll act like we're further enough
apart I think they will you think they
won't yeah but I'm not confident well
I'm fairly confident it's like a 60 40
that I don't think that he will I'm
going 70 30. uh confused so we have that
then in a mug club today we didn't even
introduce you thanks thanks for just
ruining it you have to cut to me I just
left I could have been like a
disembodied voice the suspense is
killing me we can help you with that
okay uh so my question uh for you right
now before we move on is uh if you were
a Russian citizen would you be willing
to be drafted and fight the war in the
Ukraine right now and not only would you
be willing to be drafted but um do you
think you'd want to fight for the
country at all I think we're seeing a
paper tiger being that I think is the
most important takeaway here and I think
it relates to China too a lot of us
think that China is going to be the next
great superpower the left is trying to
convince us of that but we also believe
that Russia had a formidable military so
what else do we not know tomorrow just
to let you know we will be streaming
live the January 6th hearings
so it's at 11 30 Eastern is it 11 30
Eastern yeah it's 11 30 Eastern I looked
up uh oh for some reason I thought it
wasn't we're going to start a little bit
before they actually start I think they
start at noon Eastern tomorrow so okay
so uh the hashtag is hashtag January 6th
we might have hashtag Crowder January 6
we'll have a promo code and we'll be
live streaming it live fact checking it
and a drinking game in the middle of the
day
three hours we'll be calling the balls
traffic exchange before the stream I'll
tell you today on muggle what my
anticipations are tomorrow by the way
all of you anyone who thinks that there
might be some legitimacy issues in any
election any election across the globe
they want to paint you as an
insurrectionist they're probably going
to go into Roger Stone Steve Bannon all
this crap that could not be less
relevant tomorrow we'll be streaming it
live uh all right you I'll say hi to
Gerald egg but uh you've already you've
already agreed high and uh he's ruined
the surprise but uh in third year I'd
say Dave land is going to be back with
us tomorrow is a quarter black Garrett
hey you have your own YouTube channel
here I do I do have my own my own
YouTube channel Channel and I'm on the
show Friday night tights okay so uh
that's what we're doing over on the nerd
Roddy Channel nerd rotten yeah but it
feels good to be back my dad asked you
and he was like what's your thing just
nerdfest nerdfest yle nerdfest.com it
was uh itself.com he has a biracial
angry virgins who read Comics just yes
it has a forward link so when you go to
that yes exactly the right place the
redirect yeah
he's so Charming he's intimidating and
then he just cuts you down you're like
wow where does that come from you're
such a ninja knows exactly what I'm
talking about like oh my God all right
damn so we have a lot to talk about here
today uh what else are we talking about
really quickly we're uh we have a Mud
Club segment that's uh a little on
Trudeau who's made an entire he made a
complete flip-flop on vaccines but
that's that's the world at this point
right this is one of those things again
let not your heart be troubled but
there's a silver lining here the world
has said yeah I remember all that stuff
we did with covet locking down the
economies and the mask and the mandates
we were wrong about that oops Yeah we
told you that a long time ago this is a
question I have for you too is do you
notice it's a rarity now to find someone
not only wearing a mask but it's a
rarity to find someone who you know
full-fledged just supports retroactively
all the lockdowns that we've done it
really is it's changed and that's a good
thing yeah you don't find them in the
real world they're all on Twitter yeah
right yes they know where to go to
congregate they are and they're all
verified all of this every single one
all those Bots are verified and and they
are also the true hero so before we get
to any of that uh of course the uh the
culture war is coming and this
non-binary Soldier uh wants you to get
I I guess I should have I just have a
trigger warning for this if you you know
don't if you're consuming food
right now so this non-binary Soldier
wants you to get locked and loaded let's
go
[Music]
can't possibly read that there's no way
you can read all of this
make no mistake
the battle is just beginning let's go
now's the time for us to stand together
with our weird Skrillex hairdos
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
mom I said I'm taping a freaking video
but it would it be if just cracked is it
he or she I don't know correct Z's
Knuckles and they just folded like
origami due to years of hormone
replacement therapy and brittle bones
I do want to see that though like a
whole line of just
people like that just coming out
fighting let's go we'll see the crazy
eyes like with my binoculars though the
crazy Iz tries to flash like William
Wallace like this will intimidate them
yeah I don't know but you're one of the
few people who has a BMI that says dead
and it's going the other way not obese
oh my gosh it's like a less effective
Xena Warrior Princess yes like oh good
thanks for the costume that was the
Ubermensch yes
[Laughter]
gosh what's up against that will win
yeah so that's that's good yeah well I
mean that's the whole thing if they're
soldiers I mean we have a military style
funeral where they put it in a Gap Kids
casket
um
Gap cell phones I have no idea
I assume so probably made in China okay
so let's uh while we're do we have
anything else I mean look this is just
this is where it's this cosplay it is
cosplay you know all about that you're a
nerd it's cosplay
um
but it's cosplay with hormones it's
cosplay with gender reassignment surgery
that's what we're having right now this
isn't clearly someone who wants to know
what they want Halloween to be every day
that's fine just you know uh just don't
don't Target the kids and tell them what
they should be uh committing uh sex
felonies yeah that's my problem you know
do what you want be your weird self over
there
from us away from us over there yes use
the corner okay so uh here's something
else is uh this we talked about this in
the CBC the Karen documentary oh my gosh
this is funny so for people who don't
realize CBC is a Canadian Broadcasting
Corporation you don't need to go to
Venezuela to see government-funded media
uh when I was growing up in Canada it
was pretty much the only news source
that existed on television as I
understand it now they might have some
others because of cable but CBC Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation by the way
Trudeau promised them like 150 million
dollars if he became a prime minister a
guess who got favorable coverage so CBC
in Canada they release a documentary
called deconstructing Karen and what
it's about is uh white women attending a
dinner party and I guess they've they've
actually willingly submitted themselves
to this where the white women uh invite
or pay or render the services of black
women women of color sorry to
chastise them to to berate them educate
is this for being racist we have a clip
to your question
[Music]
says with a black person in this Society
raise your hand nobody
[Music]
don't know the answer to that well it's
yes or no how many of you would do it
I needed a Hispanic
to do that but I was going to have
children so I spent many years thinking
of myself having very dark-skinned
children
questions
jaundice would be willing to trade
places
[Music]
okay I'm not saying there's not racism
absolutely not it's a stupid question
yeah but you know how racist this
country is not to the degree that you do
oh no you will never know
[Music]
we created the criminalization of black
people I'm sorry what and when your skin
was seen as a weapon you're never
unarmed and that's why black boys and
men and women are dying in the street
with their hands up
slightly thicker hair to Jada Pinkett
Smith yes
somebody's getting slapped wait when
your skin got some here is a weapon you
are always armed also all white people
are devils I just like to make that
clear that's exactly what the Sue said
what are they doing what are they doing
at the scene of the crying a little
baggy they'd have a skin graft like oh
he was carrying a 44 melanin
locked and loaded this is just what
first off I don't know if this is if
this is a taking place in at CBC I don't
know if they're trying to say the United
States is racist or Canada is racist a
lot of people don't realize that slavery
existed all across the globe including
places like Canada including other
English yeah you know British colonies
um and by the way can we bring up can
you guys bring up the definition of
racism
yeah a belief that a race is a
fundamental determinant of human traits
and capacities and that racial
differences produce an inherent
superiority of a particular race a
particular race so this is no no you're
miss the most important part is the
superiority it's not the differences
they lump it all in the idea that a race
is superior because has of racial
characteristics that's the important
component of the definition not that
there are differences and let me just
let me just say this really quickly is
um we talked about this uh I don't know
if it was last week look if I say for
example
and if you agree with everything and
then say no no that's my thing and you
get offended you have a prominence it
could be the same same principle here
applied to gender if I say for example
hey men are primarily providers
protectors men need to be held
accountable men shouldn't be cheating
being a philandering prick is a bad
thing and you could say yes and I say
and women by the way have a role in the
household of being submissive to their
husband no no no well then hold on a
second that's a u problem now if I were
to say that Asians on average here in
the United States score higher on their
SATs or IQ tests typically than members
of all other races as a general rule of
course you would have to accept it
because Brown and Harvard had to create
a policy to say no more of you because
that's the case now if I were to say hey
black uh black people the the fastest
black runners tend to be faster than the
fastest white Runners you would look at
the world records one through 25 and say
oh okay all right that makes sense now
if I were to say Asians on average score
higher on the SATs or have higher IQs on
average than black people no no wait
then you have a problem that's a you
problem you're not being honest you're
reacting with a guttural emotional
response and and that's the issue that
they're playing on yeah absolutely one
what I was saying there is black people
can be racist too that's the thing that
I've heard from so many people is the
politicism can only go one way it's
white people against black people or
other you know racist Asians whatever it
is but black people can be racist too
and some of the things she said there
were kind of like that question is
stupid to me would you trade places or
the white person not because why did a
Mexican once yes yeah what is that
street cred you know and I've had to
think about my son having dark skin I
didn't thought what that was so weird it
was weird a side story that she said
would you cover them in pancake why
would you have a dark cake what's what's
wrong with you
you know looking just like you but
that's a stupid question because nobody
really understands what it would be like
to trade places with any other human
being much less somebody of A different
race or culture right right so you ask
that question to just set it up like
black people have it so rough that you
would never want to trade places really
LeBron James does he has it so rough
that I would never want to trade places
with LeBron James I can't find a single
white person that doesn't want to be the
that would not like to be LeBron well
I've said this before but yes my my
brother he's he's full black all black
right yeah he goes into a store and go
how did that happen how's your brother
full black is it like the oh I was gonna
say like the Muppets where all the when
Kermit and piggy had kids
or Piggies okay no he's adapted uh so he
goes into goes into stores and he gets
pulled over by the cop once and he's
like I'm getting racially profiles
driving while black and I'm like dude
I've been pulled over like six times
okay yeah and I get pulled over out of
the car searched the car all this stuff
just because I had a late shift I was
driving at night a lot so I got pulled
over all the time yes but I'm like you
you saw the same thing that happens to
everybody else in the world sure and but
you see it because you're black you go I
am being racially oppressed it's like no
you're just experiencing life like
everybody else does you're not special
everybody has bad things happen and of
course look of course are there racists
out there no one is denying that but
this the only person I see there who is
a racist at that table definitively is
that old black lady
definitively she is the one making these
broad generalizations now I get it to
white women maybe they're dumb granted
and they're oblivious of course but
they're just saying well I'm not saying
there's not racism I'm just saying that
you know I don't really I don't see it
as much or I'm not racist she's going
yeah but it's a weapon if you have dark
skin yeah but this is an inherently
racist country yeah but we have white
people have criminalized black those are
generalizations that first off are
untrue and also are intensely racist
that's the only race I'm not saying that
all black people are racist just like
I'm not saying all white people racist
at that table that documentary the irony
should not be lost on you
the only race is sitting there is the
old slightly thicker here Jada Pinkett
Smith we have some stats as well uh so
from Rasmussen uh 18 of people pulled
said most white Americans are racist but
25 believe most black Americans were
racist and then among blacks themselves
uh Black Americans 31 think most blacks
are racist compared to 24 considered
most whites races so even black people
black people yeah there's a lot of like
even within you could be 100 black and
still have different skin tones and they
can treat you differently because you
have light skin or dark skin it's a it's
definitely a thing so it's like the
other day they were saying that about
the the light-skinned persons or the
darker skinned person was saying that a
light-skinned black person doesn't have
it the same and yeah they don't count
because they don't have the same
experience as white aligned or or
whatever it's it's like these things
don't make anything we need a chart of
like skin Shades and calipers like well
hold on a second if they're a little bit
like if it's cream coffee that's a 22
okay if you start getting into you know
a slightly darker territory like this
would be the sort of Will Smith category
well you're now dealing with uh you know
maybe a 380 ACP and then of course once
you get to the All-State guy you're at
45 yeah Wesley Snipes
and then of course we have up at the uh
the 300 Blackout that is the pack pirate
from Captain Phillips
scraggly I am the winner yeah this is
the problem with we have it so good
right now that everything is a
fabricated problem where we have to try
and create more racism where it doesn't
and make no mistake this documentary is
going to create more racism this is my
concern we grew up in a post-racial
America we really did and if you're a
young person right now and you're
growing up and this is the kind of
content that you are consuming you are
going to be more racist than Millennials
or older Generations who grew up where
Fresh Prince family Matt right now there
wasn't a bet it wasn't so fractured if
you grew up with with a diet of this you
are going to resent people solely based
on that race whether they're white
whether they're black this and that's
the goal uh by the way it's a live show
Monday through Thursday 10 a.m Eastern
of course tomorrow we're streaming
January 6th so it's a little bit uh
different the January 6th hearing so you
can tune in on Monday through Thursday
10 a.m Eastern on rumble on mud club.com
and the best thing you can do if you're
watching is um share the show uh
whenever you're watching the show just
share it like those things help with the
algorithms you know we kind of rely on
you for that so thanks it's terrible
it off hey the only thing worse than
your stupid jokes is your production
value yeah you boys should really
consider calling in a union so they
could become more professional so the
teamster could punch Crowder right in
the face
that was rude wow
it's getting personal unnecessarily what
was that I don't that wasn't I don't
know why we installed the balcony I
don't know why we gave them season
tickets that's on me that's a me problem
that's been been Solomon's guests I know
I'm not a businessman I thought
that's a weird addition I thought it was
profit for the taking now uh you guys
can uh we can move on here and hit the
like button if you're watching really
quickly uh here's a tale of two
robberies I guess we'll call this uh
pretty quickly
not expecting that at all so uh we had a
couple of robberies take place and I
want to see if you can Spot the
Difference remember the whole stop Asian
hate remember that's oh wow
sorry Asians you're no longer a useful
tool for the left now we've stayed on it
uh because we've been accurate regarding
the crime statistics we care about you
we actually care as we care about all
Americans I want fewer robberies period
which is why I support the Second
Amendment I want fewer rapes I want
fewer robberies I want fewer law abiding
citizens to be the victims at the hands
of uh animalistic criminals
now uh here we go the first robbery that
we're going to show you happened in
Delaware where um a robber pistol
whipped of course
uh an Asian Jeweler
there's no audio that's right there's no
audio Yeah I'd like to so that's that
Asian Jeweler uh oh no an old Asian lady
jeez or man and uh that's a lady that's
an old Asian it's tough to see with the
security camera
it's an old age
oh okay that's right I'm confusing the
clips that we have
so he's not happy with pistol whipping
this person onto the ground what the
hell doesn't just go and start stealing
things either hits him with kicks him
hits him with a hammer by the way this
guy should be walk now from the brain
damage yeah that that guy um that guy
forfeits his right to live yep that man
forfeits his right to live just to be
clear and this is again of course we
know you look at the interracial crime
statistics there um let me give you some
some brief stats again this is why I
bring up the idea of stop Asian hate
because it was used again as a political
tool for a while 85 of all assault
crimes in the San Francisco area the Bay
Area were black on Asian
okay
um 25 28 of all violent crimes committed
against Asians is committed by a black
uh perpetrator now
um here's one thing that you need to
know after uh about 2008 the reason we
have to use local statistics is because
uh the Bureau of Justice stopped
publishing data on interracial crime now
I know some we have all the references
available a lot of credit.com you'll say
I can see who committed a crime in their
race sure you might be able to see the
victim of a crime in the race Shore you
do not see interracially related crime
that's why we often have to use older
stats if it's a national level or go to
some kind of local data like you have in
the Bay Area now why do you think that
is wouldn't that be relevant especially
if you're talking about the people on
the left who want to quote unquote stop
Asian hate right we want to get to the
root cause of the problem who's
committing
violence against Asians who was elected
president in 2008 thanks Obama
Obama's administration the Bureau of
Justice decided when he was elected that
we would stop highlighting that right I
wonder I wonder if that cleared the way
for some of the stuff that we saw after
that where you know we had Trayvon and
then we had all the other issues with
hands up don't shoot and all this other
stuff and it's like all we have is this
is an example this is what we see in the
media now we're not seeing any
statistics on on black on Asian or black
on white crime we're just saying these
videos it was a great United States man
yeah yes he fixed racism if I had a son
he would probably look like Trayvon oh
that's certain to unite the country
right right yeah seriously and the white
lady said I pictured my son like Trayvon
I dated a Mexican one Mexican one
I love that it's like the Mexican it was
the lady next to the black lady a
Mexican lady because she looked Hispanic
I have no idea
Gerald you sure you want to wade into
these Waters right now that was not the
question thank you
I love the fact that she can ask like
one simple question and then the whole
room erupts into like no no I'm not the
bad one it's not me I'm not the bad I'm
not racist no no and she's just sitting
there like that's why by the way on an
unrelated note and I'll get back to the
screen that's why women are often angry
towards like feminists I think they hate
men in a lot of ways because we're
better than them at friending and what
do I mean by that what I mean is
I have my best friend is the same same
best friend since I was 12 years old you
know I've known jail for 14 plus years
like I I have very long that's most guys
that's the rule rather than the
exception it's actually in my experience
and again you know what you can comment
below ladies it's not very typical that
girls have the same friends from high
school and college they kind of cycle
through this because the way women argue
the way women fight they don't get out
of their system right just doesn't come
to fisticuffs and then you okay you go
back to being friends there's gossip you
end up creating factions and you see it
right there where all of the other white
they start all the other white witches
just throw one under the bus like not me
she's racist like not me I saw a black
kid once and they're like oh okay
and I smiled yes yeah
no she's like now you asked him to carry
your luggage that one time but I tipped
well
over 20 so anyways that's just a theory
that I have now so you saw that right
there you saw that that horrible crime
was committed against that Asian Jeweler
my mistake was a a man
uh now let's look at this clip where um
a man tries to use an old lady a grandma
as a human shield and uh with a firearm
tries to uh knock over what looks like a
bodega or convenience store see if you
can spot the difference okay
another one
now tell me that's not a happier ending
save that old lady by the way the guy
lived so it's okay for us to show the
footage but there's some funny things
there uh
I know you're gonna say it's not funny
incorrect first off
the guy robbing the store looks to be
looks to be carrying like a desert eagle
I was going to say which is which
clearly means it's an airsoft gun it's
like chromed out he has like the blinged
one exactly and then he also there it is
yeah that's an air pistol that does not
look like that's probably not a real gun
especially when you look at how he drops
it in the rate of fall but then what I
love in particular is when the
shopkeeper who by the way didn't kill
him uh but start shooting at him his
first thought is I I need to I need to
lower my visor like that's going to do
anything
again yeah watch let's watch that
portion of the clipping yeah here we go
my shield
hey instincts you never know what's
gonna I mean into a robber old lady
that's like a flashing flower that's
just a level up if you can use her as a
human shield these people are like she's
had her time yeah yes it's mine now I
want to see more videos like that than
the former and you know people this is a
fundamental difference in world view
okay if you see that video and you say
oh it would have been better if they
resolved it without violence you and I
are not going to find Common Ground I
disagree with you because you can never
know the intent of a criminal you just
know that they're willing to break the
law to hold you at gunpoint when you've
done nothing you've not violated the
non-aggression principle and you don't
know if that bed is going to kick you
while you're done down causing a brain
hemorrhage as we just saw with the Asian
Jeweler you have no idea that's why the
statistics fax the data matter who was
most likely to commit a crime against
whom why
what's the recidivism right and this is
something we need to look at across the
board and what is your greatest chance
if you're a shopkeeper if you're if
you're a woman if you're a homeowner at
protecting yourself well you know what
before we get to guns dog have a big old
dog that's the best thing you can do and
you should have a firearm and I think
that it's a great evil to rob anyone of
their right to self-defense why because
if you rob that man of his right to
self-defense he just as easily could
have been kicking the head on the floor
yeah yeah he could have been killed
because we've talked about this all the
time and it's stupid that we have to
repeat it but criminals tend not to pay
attention to the law right it's funny
all you're doing is right all you're
doing is basically preventing people
from defending themselves in these
situations and I I agree with you 100
there are so many cases where I I'm
sorry but I would be shooting a lot
earlier in some of these cases because I
have no idea what the intent is of this
person and especially if my family's
around I'm the last line of defense if I
go down my wife and kids are now in
Jeopardy I have no idea where you're
going to stop I have no idea if you're
going to kill them if you're just going
to rob us I'm sorry you've created a
situation where now I have to defend
their lives as well I feel like people
people that say why didn't they resolve
that in a non-violent way have never
been in a situation no like that in
their lives this guy's down on his luck
how do I know that right I can't
possibly know and by the way a PSA for
everyone this is this is a 100 being
genuine here if someone holds you at
gunpoint in a public area and they want
you to go into a private area this is
one of the first things you need to know
do not do it no right if someone holds
you at gunpoint says okay they want your
watch they want your wallet do that
first but if they say get on your knees
nope if they say going to this Alleyway
or follow me absolutely not that is one
of the primary mistakes that people make
if someone is willing to put if
someone's willing to train a gun on you
and then is willing to demand that you
go with them privately and quietly you
really are several steps in at this
point and you're better taking your
chances in a public area and I would
rather you take your chances in a public
area and you know be a little Coy about
it like oh uh my back and you pull out
your heater
ninja what make them swiss cheese
exactly yeah that's what I call it's a
feel-good happy ending and by the way
um this is one of those uh uh instances
where um you've heard also this isn't
the first time the Walgreens it was just
recently loaded yeah this is something
and I know you're saying which one so
it's countless uh it's been all over the
media and unfortunately it was leaked
which I'm not thrilled about this is
going on across the country these these
spats of violence um this was actually
we're producers part producers on this
and it was actually leaked it was
supposed to be in this week's edition of
of no cops
tonight on no cops hey hey service no no
I'll never swim outside
we already there
it's too bad
get a job
[Music]
security guards like yeah you'll see
yourselves on YouTube
laughs
it's just another day
23rd animation there you go
that's what happens
stay tuned for more no cops
[Music]
money not well spent producing that show
seems anti-climactic yeah you know you
know waiting for somebody to get thrown
down the times we live in all right so
now we can before we move on you know
CNN right now is obviously talking about
uh is talking about Russia but before we
show what CNN uh is talking about right
now
um I don't know if you've been watching
this they have a new installment on CNN
and it's just a documentary about the
least effective glasses ever this man is
the subject right here anyway oh
what
he's like I want to be able to look over
my glasses at all times
there's no possible way those can work
if they're reading glasses why are you
wearing them on air yeah is there a new
affectation and if they're not reading
glasses why did you say
um I want them to I want them to
resemble looking through a keyhole can
you give me the keyhole glasses
percent of his vision field is covered
by that is like if I look here I'm great
if I look slightly here I'm not right
can't see a thing outside of that what
if he sneezes he's blind gone and I'm
driving later right
so good luck you can see the two feet in
front of his car that's it yeah his
field of vision is 20 and the rest is
just covered by cataracts hey CNN stress
the name of news so now we can go on to
to Russia this is what everyone is
talking about and I think Gerald and I
have a little bit of a disagreement here
not a huge one but the jumping off point
if you've been following this is of
course uh Vladimir Putin granted and by
Vladimir Putin I mean someone who's
moving his corpse like a yeah you know
Weekend at Bernie's hiding he granted
citizenship to 75 uh foreign-born
residents and in this included of course
uh the big news Edward Snowden here you
go right before we were coming on the
air Edward Snowden we found out is now a
Russian citizen President Vladimir Putin
signing a decree today granting that
citizenship to Snowden the former NSA
contractor behind what a house
investigation found to be the most
damaging leak they said of classified
information in this country's history
Snowden had been in Exile in Russia for
nine years but the state department
spokesperson saying today he's still a
U.S citizen too they believe while
making this point about snowden's new
Russian citizenship watch
Mr Snowden should return to the United
States where he should face justice as
well get right on the American citizen
would perhaps he's intimidated it has
changed is that as a result of his
friends
apparently now he may well be
conscripted to fight in Russia's war in
Ukraine on the front lines known by the
way that's not true he's never served in
the military so he won't be asked to
fight right in their military I should
say right come on for Cornell he's a
celebrity he's a celebrity I know good
script celebrity citizenship Snowden
Brigade yeah and it's often tough for me
to keep track of who leaked when we're
talking about Snowden and Assange and I
even realize I forgot a Chelsea Manning
Chelsea what was the Chelsea was it was
it Bradley Bradley It's Bradley Manor
Bradley man Chuck became
Chucky so here's the thing uh he's been
in Stone's been in Russia since 2013.
okay let's recap this really quickly and
this is obviously nothing but posturing
for Putin why Russia is failing
miserably yeah okay he has to look
strong when now and this also will tie
into China here in a multitude of ways
because we always thought that the
Russians had a really strong military
and this is the myth of not only the
Russian soldier but we had this with the
Russian athlete remember we thought
about you had the Miracle on Ice right
you had Alexander Carolyn probably the
most dominant uh athlete in any sport of
all time uh until he got beaten by rulon
Gardner if you guys haven't watched some
of his highlight reels this man was
lifting and suplexing 300 pound man we
thought the Russians must have this
unbelievable Trend until we found out
that they were walking human pin
cushions yeah they found out that they
were cheating they were breaking all of
the rules and once you if you take that
away from any form of competition
internationally they don't tend to fare
so well so it's the same thing with the
military we thought they must have this
incredibly powerful military no it was
propped up it's not actually real and
let me give you a couple of reasons why
it's pretty hard to get people to fight
for a nation that oppresses them yeah
that they don't actually believe in we
like to believe that they're really
loyal to Mother rush and by the way
it's just one corrupt crap hole Ukraine
fighting another crap hole Russia to be
clear that doesn't mean that I'm Pro
Putin so the people out there who try
and actually take you know take this
contrarian view of Putin's actually
great well guess what his own people
don't think so just to be clear they
don't want to fight for this guy this
idea that they love the motherland
Russia it's not true we're seeing it how
uh you just had Putin have to he had to
mobilize was it 300 something thousand
oh we have an overlay yeah 300 000
something reservists for reserve us for
active duty initially that's just
starting off point and like we've got to
send some more human you know Shields
everybody on the on the Russian side
just seemed to be like yes we are
fighting y'all yes oh Mother Russia
Mother Russia right take me please set
me out of here where's the Ukrainian say
what you want about them they actually
believe that they're fighting for
something now unfortunately the
Ukrainian people aren't really
accurately or fairly I should say
represented by their leadership because
it's one of the money laundering
capitals of the world and Corruption
knows no bounds in Ukrainian leadership
but that doesn't mean that the Ukrainian
citizens are not fighting for someone
that they believe in show me and you
know what you can comment below can you
think of any examples of subjugated
people waging an incredibly successful
we're making more effective soldiers
than the non-subjugated people that they
were fighting now I don't mean
subjugated people fighting other
subjugated people technical government
right forcing people to fight for them
versus another tyrannical government I
mean if free people losing amass to a
subjugated people
there might be some examples I'm willing
to bet they're they're few and far
between and certainly as far as the
ratio to examples of of the reverse now
I think we actually have a clip the
response to the order from Putin where
protests they broke out all over Russia
yeah
foreign
[Music]
that guy got off lucky
them away Queen
and uh by the way of course you've had
you've had Russians for those who don't
know all references are available.com uh
they've burned down multiple
conscription centers you have Russians
who are fleeing the country to avoid
conscription right to avoid being forced
into the military and you have thousands
of cars you have another clip this is
something that is it is quite striking
to see yeah and I know some of you say
this is just Western propaganda no look
this is something that is happening and
I am someone who is a
non-interventionist I don't think we
should be involved with Ukraine and
Russia I've been very very clear about
that
but I can also you know call some balls
and Strikes where I see them you have
thousands of cars that are fleeing
Russia into Georgia uh Georgia into
Kazakhstan even into Finland we have we
have it's it's it's one of those Eerie
sites when you actually see it it was uh
that looks like deep impacts five or six
kilometers long yeah this is a
post-apocalyptic scene that you're gonna
see in just a minute we're like there's
just cars everywhere so people just
trying to clean their country
yeah it looks like every beginning to a
zombie movie ever trying to get out of
your country so desperately
hey sorry really fast uh we are having a
stream issue on Rumble and it's on their
end because of the hurricane so if
anyone's watching or they're having
trouble getting the stream just let them
know that you know they need good luck I
gotta watch on YouTube so go to
michael.com and if you haven't joined
yet we'll have a we will of course have
a discount code tomorrow when we do the
live stream uh by the way I know before
some of you the critics right now
we're saying see this is what you get
climate change keep in mind keep in mind
just for context it is it is hurricane
season in Florida yeah Fair Point Fair
points there's another video so I want
people in the control room there's
another video that shows the line of
cars from the air and I think it has
like an overlay of like shot shot shot
on it because it's um propriet it's
somebody else's footage right so they
wanted to have their like Watermark
basically on it so look for that one
okay yeah
um no but that's that's one of the the
the videos that I want you guys to see
but Putin Putin is losing his grip it
seems on the Russian country the people
right he's not the popular leader that
he's always made himself out to be
obviously but now that it comes down to
we have to go and die in another country
for a failing objective that you guys I
mean everybody thought that this would
be a couple of weeks and Putin would
take over right we didn't we didn't
think Ukraine would be able to stand up
this long there's no way anybody wants
to die and of course they're able to
stand up this long because of
international support and you know your
tax dollars right which makes him very
very dangerous he's trying to look
strong he's trying to say I'm gonna
thumb my nose in the face of the
Americans I'm gonna make Snowden a
citizen that's a very small step forward
in in this debate but when we get to the
news we're trying to take the little
wins where you can yeah he's like yeah
you're going to do that and since 58 58
billion I'll give citizenship to this
Joseph Gordon-Levitt type if he really
wants to piss us off just send us back
Brittany Griner and we'd be like ah
no it's do send her back yeah send her
back we want her back now on the next
flight oh by the way they can't do that
because one-way plane tickets out of
Russia have sold out so again you can
look at you can say that we have
propaganda in media of course all across
the globe but yeah these are objective
measures that you see when you see the
cars right and then you also see that
the the plane tickets have sold out
these are things that are pretty
difficult to lie about especially in
today's Information Age by the way the
Russian State media is even starting to
turn on uh on Hey look it's uh Wednesday
items right there on CNN that's a
wonderful way for a professional
broadcaster to look the orphan
95 year old he brought into your house
as a 14 year old there's a sequel for
that there is here's the Russian State
media actually starting to turn on Putin
I think we have a clip
episode
that means
wow they said drag that person out by
the ear and shoot them in public I love
it
yes yes I love how for people who are
listening in audio it's and I'll give
you the translation where uh but I'll
give you the translation with the accent
because that's how they often do it and
she's like uh I I am he's like why don't
we shoot them she's like I am against
shooting people I I but I like shooting
people we should shoot the people and
drag them into grave that's a general
translation saying that Andre saying to
grab the recruiter grab them by the ear
and you'll shoot you shoot I don't like
shoot I like shoot but I like shoes so I
think we should and I am dressed as in
bison yes
I do not like to shoot point taken
Counterpoint I enjoy to shoot
I think I win yes as you can if I have
to consider what you like I granted I
understand to not shoot and what I like
versus to shoot
I should yeah but can you imagine saying
that against an officer or an official
in the government this is a recruitment
center officer somebody who's leading
the charge in getting people in right
and you're saying we should take them
out and publicly shoot them so that the
public can just be forewarned like this
this is this kind of thing you know
we're just gonna do it yeah probably
catch more flies with vinegar like these
guys are signing their own death
warrants by speaking out against Putin
in in years past well they also might be
thinking of course again he's weakened
right and Now's the Time and they feel
emboldened enough because they feel like
though as though there's a Groundswell
in in Russia because a lot of people
don't want to go and fight for a corrupt
government yes Ukraine is corrupt but so
is Putin so is the administration that
Russia is currently dealing with and so
people do not want to put their lives on
the line for something that they don't
believe in subjugated people typically
historically not always don't have the
motivation to go to war and lay their
life down it's not like a William
Wallace type situation it's not like an
American Revolution situation just to be
clear and by the way this is what we've
been saying about China or what I've
been saying about China for years you
know the left has wanted us to believe
uh that China is the next great
superpower right for years this is what
experts have been saying I think this is
an overlay collage e again if you don't
believe me you can check this from the
guardian this is from uh Fortune the
Atlantic
I don't buy it now what Donald Trump did
is he served a purpose in saying no we
can have some sanctions we can have some
punishments we can make sure that our
trade is on equal is on an equal playing
field with China the reason the left
will say well don't do that don't piss
them off because they're all powerful
but why do we think that could it be for
the same reasons that we thought the
Russian military was effective
we thought they were far more effective
than we know them to be what do you
think happens in China when for decades
you have the people again who've been
it's a third world country it's a third
world country for everybody except for
the select few shows and you've been
building sneakers you've been building
genes and you've been building uh
smartphones that you never get to use
what do you think happens when someone
goes to war with that country and they
say wait a second these people want to
liberate us and allow us to actually
have access to all of these things that
we've been having to create through
slave labor I'm not saying it's a
guarantee what I am saying is the left
because of their globalist world view I
don't want to use the term agenda
because immediately this will be
dismissed out of hand but because of
their belief in global trade and of
course not wanting to piss off China
they've said oh no the consequence will
be too severe because China's holding
the cards I don't think they are just
like I don't think the Russian military
is all that impressive and if you
believe it guess what that changes so
many aspects of the United States we
have films that we have to change so it
appeases the Chinese market yeah we have
to make sure we have to craft our trade
agreements to make sure that we don't
piss off China hey you know what what's
the what's the worst that'll happen
it could be bad but maybe it's not as
bad as the left wants you to believe and
certainly it's not a black or white
issue where you have to count out of
China at every single step lest you piss
them off because they have the upper
hand on us in every single facet this is
where I see a parallel that I hope
people can learn from this we thought
Russia was something that it's not I am
Telling You China is something we
thought them to be and they are not yeah
absolutely and it was all about dollars
right it was all about corporations and
media kind of Corporations wanting to
have access to the Chinese market to the
Chinese people like you said the ones
that were I mean they have so many
people that's the ones that are the
select few they can drive an economy a
little bit they can make a movie do very
very well over there but most of the
country lives and I I don't know I'm not
saying most like a stat but most of the
country lives in abject poverty look at
some of the countryside the vast
majority vast majority I would think
right so don't don't fact check me on
that but maybe our researchers can find
out what poverty level they have if they
would actually release that number but
they saw dollars three scorpions cooked
in Seward [ __ ] yes but that's uh that's
a cultural differences you know sure
Different Strokes but every one of these
corporations probably thinks the same
thing about our impossible Burgers
including right now with the NBA
including right now with Hollywood are
Cowtown to them it was a self-fulfilling
prophecy okay you guys are going to get
pissed off if we don't say what you want
us to say so we will build you up so
that we can have access to your market
and now because we've done that and only
because we've done that China has any
power in the world at all right only
because of us it is our fault that China
is anything that they are right now even
if they're not as much as we think they
are whatever they are it is absolutely
our fault for doing it and we can also
like Donald Trump thought we can turn
the clock back you think you're
something that we need to be afraid of
we'll put some sanctions on you we'll
hurt your economy really quickly and
show you the only reason you exist is
because of us right that's it yeah what
happened that's what needs to happen
what happens when you turn off their
consumer pool yeah their own people
can't be consumed they're selling that's
the big difference between the United
States and by the way the rest of the
world but even let's just okay let's
take a microcosm here take Russia energy
right or uh was it uh Ukraine
wheat right do you have these this yeah
it's not for us red baskets we're the
bread yeah we're the bread well they're
the Bread Basket of the world right yeah
we're the BR we really could be our own
Bread Basket the same thing with energy
we don't need to rely on Russian energy
we don't need to rely on Russian oil
whatsoever we could be in we were a net
export of oil for the first time in
decades under Donald Trump I know the
numbers in front of me but it was it was
startling I remember covering that it
was also struggling when drug prices
went down for the first time these were
these were Monumental victories for the
American people but China okay turn off
the American Consumer they don't have a
consumer pool we have our own consumer
pool and we can have our own production
pool we can be our own producers we can
be our own suppliers we can be our own
Distributors and we can be our own
consumers China can be a supplier China
can be a distributor they can't be the
consumers
that's a that's a very large uh shift
that they would have to make and it
would have to be a shift toward Freedom
which they can't do if they want to
continue to subjugate people and
maintain an Economy based on slave labor
see they're stuck between a very little
they have a very little Dixon device now
just mean the Communist Chinese
government the Communist Chinese
government right there's a direct
correlation between being a Chinese
Communist and a small penis really let's
get this stuff
and I mean annual uh per capita
disposable income uh in China is 2 647
wow in rural China versus uh in the U.S
per capita is 63 000. that's a little
different
how in the hell is it 63 000 in rural
United States versus that's disposable
income United States
fight for 15. that's 30k a year trying
out loud everyone would have John
Deere's with spinners well some do now
um could you give me some examples like
I was talking about this earlier too is
uh sorry that was that was GDP oh yeah
all right that makes sense uh a small
motivator like a fighting force right
can be far more effective than a large
unmotivated one so you have Vietnam
right and you can look at some of these
people versus both the United States and
versus China right if you look at uh
what happened in Vietnam you have the
mujahideen versus Russia you have you
want to go back historically at like the
Spartans versus the Persians and again
they only held them off for a while uh
Finland versus Russia in the uh the
winter War I didn't even know about that
one Finland versus Russia in the winter
War yeah that was during World War II I
didn't even know yeah it was turns out
Russia sucked for a while yeah and who
knows how they would have done if it
didn't starve their people to death well
you know through communism Marxism no no
wait sorry that's right you say that was
leninism it wasn't communism tried right
so still waiting on that old swing at
bat get a lot of chances though yeah too
many chances I think yes I agree that's
why we should shoot
the point makes more sense now it does
make more it makes sense when you think
you know what it's hard to argue with
that logic just yeah he likes it I like
it you see Communists you shoot it's a
matter of fact it's better to shoot now
and just shoot now that's a just shoot
just that's it now there's no step two
no paperwork and maybe maybe if you are
feeling ambitious put in Shallow Grave
so uh what do you think Putin's gonna do
this is the conversation we want to have
yeah and by the way hit the like button
if you can that helps again with the
algorithm right now if you're watching
we'd love to hear you you know discuss
along with us since we're not on Rumble
here today we apologize rumble's having
some issues looks like Rumble just
popped back up hey Rumble what's up I
couldn't speak more incorrectly as well
let's jokes back up everybody hey thanks
Rubble rumbles down wait a minute the
Hurricane's going to hit on Thursday
it's Tuesday
yeah Rumble get your crap together
be like it's early tornadoes very early
their servers are in Cuba so oh oh
that's that's got to be what it is yeah
um so last week Putin and this comes
down to you think it's saber rattling or
do you really think that they're going
to actually do this he threatened a
nuclear attack
to defend Russia and our people yeah we
will certainly make use of all weapon
systems available to us all of them
this is not a bluff the citizens of
Russia can rest assured by the
territorial Integrity of our motherland
our independence and freedom will be
defended I repeat by all the systems
available to us
those who are using nuclear blackmail
against us should know that the wind can
turn their way well hopefully the wind
doesn't hit the trailer home from what
you're broadcasting
look here look at my early 70s wood
paneling you'll know I am serious I am
real Oak yes I am not playing games with
my formica
what a piece of [ __ ] I love okay so
focus on what he said territorial
Integrity what does that mean it means
that if somebody attacks Russia they
will defend ah okay so he's just started
to change this he's basically saying
those Ukrainian provinces that those
regions that we think are part of ours
now they are ours now they actually had
a referendum or a vote on that basically
he said yep that's part of our country
now so in any attack there is Attack on
Russia yeah I know so this is why I'm
saying like he's just setting the stage
so you're saying you do think and you
guys let us know we'll be taking a chat
on mug Club you think yeah a tactical
nuke which probably would be just
obviously just you know Ukraine is what
you're talking about right I think he
would use the Tactical nuke in Ukraine I
don't think there's any threat to any
other country right now what odds do you
put on that what percentage
it's really I don't want to like you
know be a doomsdayer but I'm I would say
probably somewhere around 60 to 70
percent chance if there's an if with
this if things continue the way they are
if they don't start making head well but
listen I don't I can't predict how these
300 000 people that have been dragged
out of the streets that's why it's
called a prediction I know so if things
continue the way that they are I do not
think Putin knows how to exit the stage
gracefully he doesn't he's a leader I
think that's a good hour that's a good
point and he would do that first and say
I am strong I used a tactical nuke in
Ukraine which is not Russia obviously so
right let me ask a rabbit dog do you
think he would have been able to exit
gracefully and maybe in less likely to
in your estimation you know drop a nuke
uh if the U.S hadn't supported Ukraine
do you think you would be able to save
face maybe a little bit more I I think
maybe but the entire world is against
him right now in the world people that
basically I think he's somewhat friends
with right now or China and I'm not even
sure they're really that interested
because look look how long it's gone
right like it's like ah yeah we're
friends with you right out of the gate
yes you can do this and it's like guys
it's been months and they didn't they
don't really have an army so uh yeah
what are we doing here kind of
embarrassing we kind of I don't think
we're friends anymore sorry like we need
supplies that just shipped them four
million copies of shinshu's Art of War
read a book
study up no I really do think this is
the end for for Putin I don't think
there's any coming back for this and you
think he might just try and burn it all
down to some too try to save it I think
his his way of saving it is looking
strong exactly no save his powers I have
to blow it up to safe so you said this a
minute ago subjugated people right so
when the leader of the country that
subjugates people starts to show
weakness starts to show that there are
cracks
all of the wolves come out every every
political enemy he's ever had ever every
person he's stolen a business from and
given it to one of his buddies every
person that he has locked up and then
you know sent off into Exile into
another country everyone will be coming
from the knives are out his only defense
is to say Edward Snowden okay yeah
exactly is Edward saying that [ __ ]
right it's gonna show up like my
baseball Series kick down his office
door pretty much his only way out is to
show Power and the only way he can do
that right now is to say we're defending
our territory and I'm using a tactical
nuke and it gives the rest of the world
like hey we're just defending our
territory you wouldn't do the same right
it's not going to fly but he's gonna try
he's still yeah of course and he would
at that point it would be beyond the
point of no return it's like at that
point it's like a puffer fish or some
kind of an animal that poisons the
animal who eats it it's like well it's
dead but it I guess it takes a little
sense
to know that you died even though they
don't get to see the small the smile on
your face kind of like putting a razor
blade in someone's Apple you don't get
to enjoy it but you know what happens
you were not advocating that by the way
somewhere off
you're just like no just trying to
understand it I would just pay to see
the smile on their face so you don't
think that's like farting in an elevator
and leaving it to that and then say it's
me when you're leaving yes what do you
think uh quarterback you think that
they'll
do you think he's going to do it he's
got pretty good points yeah uh which is
shocking that um
yeah I think he's losing power and he's
losing faith so he's gonna just pull the
trigger if he's got the Button he's
gonna do it yeah I think it's a highway
I would say maybe like 60 40 he doesn't
that would be if I hadn't it so there's
there's a 40 chance even in your
estimate yes we're gonna see another
nuclear weapon be used in on the
battlefield yes that's that I think it's
I think it's less likely than likely but
I'm not confident about it that's and
that's that's terrifying because I would
love for that to be like oh 80 chance
that he's not right like I see it
because I don't see any any way out for
him you know the other the other
scenario which I would probably put an
80 chance on but there could also
somebody takes him out
to account because he said once they see
weakness the wolves come out but yeah
this isn't going to be like the gray
he's not going to take a broken bottles
all right let's do this yeah come on
they're five foot two they're even
people saying that he had fled Moscow
and was actually in hiding somewhere I
have no idea if that's true or not I
think that's a very likely scenario yeah
that whether they actually take him out
physically or there's a meeting in the
back room with look you want to say face
go away and don't ever let us see your
face again there's a very strong
likelihood of that because I don't think
I don't think that the rest of the
ruling class who by the way we were just
talking about replacing them with an
it's a Russian political corruption
nesting dog it is just another one and
another one and they don't want their
resources to be destroyed they want to
be able to save face and say well look
Putin we got rid of him and then
subjugate them with a new lie right so
somebody needs to break navalny out of
prison right now he's in in a Russian
prison and he is the guy to come in and
Lead that country away from the current
trajectory right he is the guy that
comes in and is a pro-democracy guy as
much as can be had in Russia and he
would be a great leader now nobody in
Putin's Circle nobody who's trying to
gain power is going to do that
militarily I would hate to see a general
have a military coup to take over but I
mean this pretty much who leads the
country anyway let's say I'm going to
restore Mother Russia you know who
should take over
I shoot that guy that's his platform
it's just hope and shoot
all right good enough for me
make shoot great again all right
that's not even your own tagline hey
vote build back shoot
Fields Back crap so all right look uh we
are going to be here tomorrow it's at 11
30 Eastern the January 6th uh hearing
could be whatever you want to call it
we're going to be calling the balls and
Strikes we'll have a drinking game and
it's something I think you need to watch
I expect there to be some fireworks here
I think I know what they'll be trotting
out we've been pretty good with our
calls on this in the past and so it's a
way for you to watch it and not want to
blow your head off tomorrow at uh is it
11 30 10 30. it's 11 30 Eastern 10 30.
they just changed the time two times in
the last 14 hours I think I think Steve
might be 11 30 Central 12 30 Eastern
that's what I thought you said 11 30
Eastern that's right are you sure no
you're wrong no man shut up I'm pretty
sure I'm right you guys what you
literally just all disagreed with each
other and then switch back again
you say another then you go back again
we're trying to tell an entire audience
to come and watch us oh you buy me nice
things that's true you buy me nice
things what is it
let's get out
I shoot I should Gerald
yes we have many guns in studio I can
shoot all of you together now is it 12
is it 12 30 Eastern early 30 Eastern 12
20 Eastern so the card was wrong I
apologize look before we leave admonish
all of us hey
[Music]
no no
no we were out here we were out guys I'm
gay I'm not says on the on the Jenny
pull up this pull up the January 6
committee webs they have a website by
the way pull up their website and look
at what time it sounds can you fit in a
room just tell me what it says
on that site
who's on the commission I think please
tell me Amy Klobuchar is because we have
that ad for Amy Klobuchar that we just
want to run we haven't found a right fit
for it yet
I hope so uh 1 pm Eastern so we'll be on
at 12 30 p.m look at that I told you so
and you guys corrected me earlier today
you know hey may I do the thinking
please
uh what's your show uh quarterback
Friday night tights on Friday erotic
Channel what is your YouTube channel
Court of black Air just like at the
bottom of the screen okay oh see I can't
stay on the bottom I have a very small
mind so uh we're going to go of course
to mugler we actually have a whole
segment on Trudeau uh and him making a
flip-flop on the vaccinations right now
if you're watching look please just like
share the show it helps with the
algorithm we've been I mean we've been
throttled again uh this is no this is
not so so tomorrow we will see you at 12
30 Eastern shut up YouTube piss off